we're at a stage now where more
information is available about you
online and on your phone
than there is in your house you know
chances are your phone knows what you've
been browsing knows your friends knows
your relationship has all of your photos
i mean just think about this and the
magnitude of information we take that
very seriously timothy donald cook had
an astounding 95
glass door approval rating in 2021 as
the chief executive officer of apple
since joining the legendary steve jobs
as the company's senior vice president
in 1998 apple has only seen good days
together with jobs tim spearheaded the
company to remarkable innovation and
success which climaxed at the san
francisco mac world convention on the
9th of january 2007 a day many call the
funeral of nokia they combined an ipod a
mobile phone and internet connection
into one revolutionary device this is
one device and we are calling it
iphone
eventually jobs stepped down and cook
became the ceo in august of 2011 and
shortly after jobs would pass on in
october of that same year tim cook has
done remarkably well at the top of the
company helping to raise its valuation
from just about 6 billion when he joined
to almost 3 trillion today the highest
valuation of any entity in human history
today we'll take a look at a day in the
life of the man that has an entity that
big tim cook a big guy
you're a big guy for you
and of course tim cook's day begins with
the sunrise well not actually you see
most ceos and regular people get out of
bed by 7 or 8 am not tim though the tech
mogul has already been up for an
astonishing four plus hours by that time
but what's he doing up by 3 45 am you
ask well mr cook is a bit of a
workaholic and he admits it when he
wakes up the first thing he does is go
through tons and tons of email and
customer comments he can go through as
many as 800 in the morning and he finds
the feedback of customers to be very
important tim cook details one of the
most email intensive moments during his
time as ceo after a terrorist attack in
san bernardino california apple was
under pressure to help with unlocking
the iphone 5c belonging to a suspect and
cook said he read all the emails of the
random people messaging him to show
support are you reading those letters
those emails i am reading every one of
them they are very heartfelt and very
emotional he typically goes through all
the messages each morning within two
hours so that by 5 am he can hit the gym
or head out for some exercise by this
time most of his employees are likely
still asleep tim says he enjoys using
his apple watch as well as other
technologies like fitness plus for his
workout routines and the ability to get
pinpoint health data best workout
routine recommendations great group
sessions and more all while shuffling
through the music of your choice just
shows why he credits his motivation to
exercise to two key things group workout
sessions and digital badges tim cook
loves loves digital badges you know
there was one for uh national park uh
recently i love getting these even if i
have not planned to work out for the day
and one of those things come up i have
to go work out it really shows that they
were one thing he doesn't do though is
use the gym at the spaceship like apple
park instead he works out at a private
gym away from the eyes of employees and
reporters and sometimes especially on
weekends he can indulge in running
hiking or cycling when he's done it's
breakfast time he eats a regular
american breakfast of a plate of
scrambled egg whites and turkey bacon
with sugar-free cereal with almond milk
he's now ready to take on the big entity
so he gets into his clothes gets into
his bmw 5 series and drives toward the
apple campus tim cook's activities at
work entail some of the most interesting
things you'll ever come across and
that's expected with a company he works
for software ar and many cool ideas each
day are the tip of the iceberg a quick
stop at starbucks for a cup of coffee
we'll see him go through a few more
emails before heading back on the route
toward the campus once again
unsurprisingly he's usually the first to
arrive at work and like the rest of the
people working at the tech giant tim's
day is heavily influenced by the park
itself after driving to the campus tim
has to park his vehicle at the two-story
car garage beneath the ring as it is
wittily called there are several bikes
within the park that he can use to get
to his location or he may decide to walk
by the beautiful gardens and green at
the center of the ring the ring is built
like a spaceship with large
floor-to-ceiling windows and glass walls
installed all through this helps to
encourage interaction between employees
mr cook's office is designed like
regular offices with the glass walls he
also eats lunch at the cafeteria in
apple park the park was also designed to
have just one cafeteria so that
interaction between colleagues is at
maximum tim cook is said to be very
attentive in meetings and conversations
while dishing out a lot of questions
it's said that employees prepare
extensively for tim's no-nonsense
attitude during meetings the more
prepared you are the fewer the questions
and opportunities to embarrass yourself
he probes employees during meetings by
asking within 10 questions depending on
how well the answers satisfy him he may
stop or ask even more as many as a
hundred his leadership style is about
thoroughness and leaving no stone
unturned on one occasion it was said
that cook remarked that they needed
someone in china to work out something
after a while he looked up at an
employee and asked what are you still
doing here and that was it the employee
took the next flight to china with
absolutely no luggage on them it's this
willingness to go all the way and drag
others along that has helped him to
raise the company to its current
valuations however the elephant in the
room means the ending comparison to the
legendary steve jobs as several
commentators say the ex-ceo was more of
an innovator and some people even say
that tim is only a great operator i mean
you can joke all you want about the
stovetop-shaped camera bump but the man
is a cook at the end of the day and
those jibes can't stand up to his actual
innovations we've already seen how
groundbreaking technologies like the
apple watch are also the effect of
fitness plus since the beginning of the
pandemic has been profound and these are
just at the tip of my tongue their foray
into the ev industry is also something
that tim works on daily while the world
and elon musk hold their breath the
world because of excitement but elon
because he needs his oxygen on mars tim
cook may take interviews and meetings
from non-apple employees within the
campus or on an outing just like the one
with donald trump that earned him the
infamous tim apple alias with all this
responsibility and power people have
even suggested that he should run for
president what do you think would he
make a better president than trump i
guess it's apples and oranges but
anyways tim doesn't seem interested he's
focused on the very important work that
he does at apple and there's a lot of it
and according to him the most important
for apple which they work to improve
each day is the user's security privacy
and the ability to not be tracked by the
apps they use your platform collectively
it appears that there have been
estimates that companies like facebook
and google and others have lost about 10
billion dollars in revenue as a function
of not being able to track users despite
being the first to get to work tim cook
is the last to leave for home night time
comes and it's the period of tim cook's
life that i know the least about you see
tim likes his users privacy because as
he once said he himself likes to enjoy a
basic level of privacy however we do
know that he tries to get some shut-eye
by 8 45 pm which then gives him seven
hours to sleep before his 3 45 am wake
up time but it is said that he still
sends emails to employees in the middle
of the night and sometimes early in the
morning so it's not safe to bet on a
sleeping pattern for the big guy at the
end of the day we can draw several
conclusions from the tech giant he loves
his job he expects a lot from his
employees but he gives even more from
himself so it's no surprise that apple
has reached heights that no one could
have imagined and surpassed it all but
like i said the tech billionaire is not
just a great operator but also an
innovator don't believe me click this
video to see all the amazing disruptive
and revolutionary technology that apple
has planned for the coming decades and
i'll see you there